there's a kindergarten teacher in france
kindergarten teacher just got fired
from teaching kindergarten he's he's
still teaching first graders and second
graders and third graders he just got
fired from kindergarten why
sylvan helene is his name he's 35 he's
the most tattooed man in
in france his body face and tongue are
covered in tattoos
and he just had the whites of his
eyeballs surgically dyed black
to look like a demon he looks like a
demon and he was scaring the
kindergarteners
so finally he was moved not out of the
not out of the school not away from
children not into a psychiatric hospital
where he belongs
he was moved to first grade and
hopefully those kids and their parents
won't complain and have nightmares
there was a time in this civilization
where you could look at that and say you
know
it's it is wrong to uh
dye your whole skin and dye your
eyeballs black and try to look like a
demon
that's wrong that's evidence that
something's gone wrong in your head and
we're gonna give you treatment for that
we're going to explain to you why that's
wrong but now we're so afraid to make
any moral moral claim and and they're
even conservatives quote unquote
they're really libertarians who say well
you know look
if we say it's wrong to uh dye your
eyeballs black and and cover your whole
body and tattoos to look like a demon
then they're gonna tell us it's wrong to
go to church and it's like who can
really know which one's wrong you know
so we just gotta throw our hands up and
anything goes
no i'll tell you what how about we just
say the good things are the good things
and the bad things are the bad things
we've done that throughout the entirety
of our civilization except for the past
i don't know five minutes
in earnest since the 1960s how about we
just do that
that is possible we have the ability to
do that
we just might not have the courage
that all of that is to say that is a
system
that conservatives are up against right
now okay that kind of
insanity that kind of unreason and so
it is no surprise that when we have our
national debates
it's just a bunch of screaming all night
long it's just a bunch of petty insults
there's no reason because we've lost
confidence even in the ability
to reason about our politics to reason
about how we ought to all
live together we've lost a conception of
what the good
even is what we all should be doing and
so we're all just stuck
in cacophony and a bunch of babel i hope
you enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you